and you meant you might have told the
story before so if it's super boring no
version but like I'm so fascinated by
how the group came to like it's a
[ __ ] it's a crazy phenomenon that
what you guys I have noted yeah it's
bonkers dude like it's available it is
crazy and the fact that that just even
pranks and stunts like I feel like
anytime somebody thinks of anything or
sees a video you immediately compared to
like oh like jackets did it better so
you know I'm saying so like that's crazy
to me so well how did it it's crazy and
it's also like it's a good feeling you
know that you're part of something so
special yeah it's it's an amazing
feeling the way I kind of see it as is
there's so many bands out there in the
world and they all start you know just
buddies and stuff but only a few like
are like you know [ __ ] Rolling Stones
ac/dc you know Black Sabbath stuff like
that yeah to have that many guys that
are in it to win it by the way yeah for
that long is legend crazy but not even
we were never in it to win it when we
first started we were in it to just
[ __ ] get the footage out but that's
what I mean yeah I think but all I
committed to the yeah yeah to what you
were doing it was I know for the album
we were in the album and in like there
there was no like Oh empty we didn't
come to you with a bag of money and say
here do they know well you know when
they first came you know we were
learning it first even aired I seriously
thought maybe one or two episodes was
gonna air and then people be like didn't
you guys try to do that one show like I
thought that's what I was getting here
down the line like 10 years later like
maybe a guy or two you know that's I
thought yeah I never thought it would be
where it's at so take so thanks - so do
you meet Johnny first how does it like
um yeah so the group form because over
here in the West Coast there was a
skateboard magazine called Big Brother
right and we split skate videos out [ __ ]
number two boob poop with his four
videos and in between the skateboarding
we did jackass stunts but we noticed
these videos were selling a lot like
more than average skate videos and we
knew it was because of the stunts are
doing and Knoxville was writing things
in the magazine I worked at the magazine
like it was one of my first jobs I was
standing out
descriptions everybody was in there yeah
so like Bob it was a cool vibe Pontius
was always coming around so we all kept
doing that stuff and terrain just said
we need to connect but at the same time
on the East Coast West Chester PA BAM
done Rab all those guys we're doing CKY
so all those secret skate videos would
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in them too
Wow so Jeff goes all right if we're
gonna do something they're doing kind of
similar we're doing let's kind of let's
collab and let's make something even
bigger and so that's what we did dang
and Stevo kept writing [ __ ] in to like
Big Brother and you can see in the big
brothers a big brother documentary it
explains the how jackass startled yeah
and it explains our Stevo was there
there was a skate tour going down in
Florida and Stevo found out and he kept
chasing like Jeff and them and they
filmed a bit of him jumping off like a
high bridge like yeah flipping off of it
yeah and when he was in the water they
tried to ditch him and Steve he like
submit videos and stuff like you I mean
Marty yeah yeah he was doing like blah
like his hair on fire doing black
backflips and doing fireballs and when
you're making and when you're doing
these stunts initially is is there a
even a thought of like this could go to
MTV or now you're just like I do know no
I didn't think what we were doing I knew
Jermaine had an idea mm-hmm and he said
he first took it to HBO and that was the
first place they walked in on they
should have no they should have but it
was two ladies that were looking it over
and it was Jermaine Knoxville and Spike
Jones it was being there in there and
Ike well we got something to show you
and these two ladies watch it so this is
the first time the pilot is being seen
yeah outside of the group or
skateboarding or anything you know right
so it's just think of just two normal
ladies baking at it and network and you
like Jason Ritter section the city kind
of they pretty much looked at
those guys and pretty much said well we
just lost 30 minutes of our lives were
never getting back that's and they
didn't know what to do so then they
regroup and and now NGO plays the
Jackass movies so yeah dude to have the
foresight to collab and bring both
coasts together is because that also
couldn't that could have baman and all
those guys could have been like nah man
we're good we're doing I don't think
yeah how did that was it like a call was
it a big group conference thing that you
guys what kind of just did it Tremayne
yeah he's the ringleader he's the he's
pretty much master
you know the creative and once it starts
airing do you remember a like your first
oh [ __ ] I think this is a thing yeah I
remember
so it was 99 mm mmm the TV show just
started airing it had been on for three
months yeah and I was still skating for
Dogtown skateboards and it was that
summer we went to Tokyo to do a tour it
just hit Tokyo and we're skating through
the city and people are running out of
stores yelling my name they're ugly man
yeah and my buddies all on the skate
team with me are like dude it's [ __ ]
over for you now yeah I'm like holy [ __ ]
for you and any other dwarf who looked
remotely like you for me to doesn't even
have to look like me either
that's I've seen yeah I've seen brother
man
dwarfs get called wee man yeah so it's
pretty psychotic yeah yeah and I've
tried to explain this to some some guys
what's what were I tell them I don't
want to be famous I just want to be rich
because it's like you know yeah I can't
hide no I even Knoxville told me yeah we
started doing it he said I'm gonna be
I'm gonna have it the worst yeah and
it's been proven that it sure because
you can't put on a hat no lasses a fake
beard like it's great my girlfriend
hates it yeah so my girlfriend we're
we're going to this restaurant fancy
restaurant mm-hmm in Kelowna BC it's
real
on the marina and it's all like very
harsh but it's like you know yeah very
hodgepodge like marina there's like nine
Forks on them yeah yeah what do I use
yeah yeah I just use one no but we were
walking by and everybody's just [ __ ]
staring at me my girl like [ __ ] we go in
and the hostess people don't even ask
nothing they just start are you that guy
better you know nobody like nobody says
hello or another name they don't
straight into it yeah and then we get
sit down at our booth and we've got a
window booth my chick and I we we order
food get a drink we have one drink a
little bit of food and my chicks like
you know when we leave we're not walking
out there we're going out the window if
there's like a window Bracey
yeah is that great she could handle it
and so I'm like all right babe you go
first and I'll follow them she said can
we get the check she [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
pulled it out check their keep change
and she jumped out and there was like a
family sitting right to the right of our
kid and they're looking at us like we're
[ __ ] dining in - Ian so she jumps out
and I look over at them I'm like oh
don't worry
we paid and then I jump out like any
time anything like that happens there's
there's probably people around like oh
this is a stunt no it's always like that
but for all the guys even for Preston
it's been like that Bret's told me
stories he's been at like a like a diner
cafe like a 50s diner and sat at the bar
like you know and eating his burger and
he had two Japanese guys come up and go
oh Preston lacy from jackass we have
been sitting here for 45 minutes waiting
for you to do something that goes nope
just eating my lines
ya think that just because you have
conditioned people to think that like
any regular situation normal
yeah I'm about to go down yeah that's
crit did you find the fandom in Japan
was like crazier than in the States like
once you got back here and things took
off really now it then it started being
both yes are being both what's crazy is
it was crazy when it came out but it's
2018 it's been eight years since we
filmed a movie
yeah and it's almost crazier now no way
than it was when it first came out
[ __ ] kid and when I hit MTV that was
that was like when MTV when he was still
like 2000 2002 2002 was TV time for
jackass yeah
that's 18 years ago was when we were on
TV but what other shows were on empty
wasn't that like I mean you got green I
think was yeah there's a handful right I
was like MTV's like they were like all
right this is Tom Green and then there
was like the real world and [ __ ] like
that it was the hot it was like the road
well yeah cuz there wasn't any other
channels you yeah like I remember to
like okay make sure you get cable cuz
you get MTV I mean right now it's like
hey so why is it even bigger now just
because of how much quicker you can see
I think so the clinicals around access
to everything and yeah I think people
talk about like oh I'm gonna do
something crazy and then their friend
goes oh yeah watch this so like you said
if somebody thinks of some are sometime
there are a lot of those vine accounts
where people were just doing crazy
stunts and now I would every time I
would see keith kids doing them I was
like oh yeah they probably watched all
your [ __ ] and we're like now I'm gonna
I'm gonna be the next crew it's like
yeah it's hard yeah and the thing is is
it's not just the stunts it's the fact
that now these you guys man you guys
we're gonna put a band together right
now yeah yeah but we're not gonna be the
Rolling Stones you know but we can cover
all their songs and all that dude the
way we would never be died do the way
girls we're watching like let's say um
you know friends me like I'm Phoebe I'm
Rachel like I'm wee man I'm steve-o
somehow I always got we men take you
silence you're definitely not danger
Ehren and Dave England yeah you don't
get to vote on that one